how freeing are we really for all my
life i thought that i could be the
orchestrator of my own symphony but if i
work hard on myself and cultivate the
right amount of self-awareness i will be
able to dictate my fate and my future
although i always assumed that free will
is something quite self-evident at some
point i had to question the reality of
this assumption that point was when i
heard my favorite contemporary thinker
sam harris asserting that free will is
an illusion
now i'm standing up here trying to
reason with you
and
you'll think
he looks a little like ben stiller
[Applause]
i was hoping i didn't look that much
like ben stiller
thoughts just emerge in consciousness
okay we are not authoring them
we we can't think them we can't choose
them before we think them that would
require that we think them before we
think them
if you can't control your next thought
and you don't know what it's going to be
until it appears
where is your freedom of will
there's so much to unpack here so let's
start with the fundamentals
understanding what sam harris wants to
say is mind-bending to say the least it
took me hours to decipher his stream of
reasoning and even now i'm not sure if i
understand completely so i will try to
elaborate on what i managed to
understand the basic premise of harry's
postulate is twofold first that we don't
have control over our background the
biochemistry of our brains and also over
the effects of our environment on our
development he writes in his book titled
free will how can we be free as
conscious agents if everything that we
consciously intend is caused by events
in our brain that we do not intend and
of which we are entirely unaware second
that there is substantial evidence that
the brain decides on our actions before
we perform them the famous libid
experiment performed by psychologist
benjamin liebert in the 80s claimed that
activity in the brain's motor cortex can
be detected some 300 milliseconds before
a person feels that they have decided to
move sam harris mentions two more
studies from 2011 in his book and
suggests that these findings are
difficult to reconcile with the sense
that we are the conscious authors of our
actions one fact now seems indisputable
some moments before you are aware of
what you will do next a time in which
you subjectively appear to have complete
freedom to behave however you please
your brain has already determined what
you will do i did my own research and
there are several people disputing the
validity of the libid experiment in any
case this is a debatable topic and
requires further investigation sam
harris essentially suggests that a
powerful mixture of determinism and
randomness shapes the reality of our
experience and since we can't control
determinism and randomness there can be
no such thing as free will
free will and what we call the self are
essentially two sides of the same coin
the self is an illusion the sense of
being an ego an eye a thinker of
thoughts in addition to the thoughts a
an experiencer in addition to the
experience that the sense that we all
have of riding around inside our heads
as a kind of a passenger in the vehicle
of the body that's that's where most
people start when they when they
think about any of these questions most
people don't feel identical to their
bodies they feel like they have bodies
they feel like they're inside the body
and most people feel like they're inside
their heads
now that sense of being a subject a
locus of consciousness inside the head
is an illusion that it makes no
neuroanatomical sense there's no place
in the brain for your ego to be hiding
we know that that everything you
experience your your conscious emotions
and thoughts and
moods and the the impulses that initiate
behavior all of these things are
delivered by by
myriad different processes in the brain
that are spread out over the whole of
the brain that they can be independently
erupted there's we have a changing
system we are a process and there's not
one unitary self that's carried through
from one moment to the next
unchanging and yet we feel that we have
this this self that's just this kind of
center of experience
so since the self is an illusion since
there is no i in the locus of experience
and we are one with consciousness
how can there be free will i think that
we are just arguing semantics here the
notion of free will was introduced as a
way for philosophers to explain the
choices people make and how much control
they have over them as it is stated in
stanford encyclopedia of philosophy from
at least aristotle onwards ancient
philosophers engaged in systematic
reflection of human agency a question
that aristotle seems to recognize while
not satisfactorily answering is whether
the choice an individual makes on any
given occasion is wholly determined by
his internal state he says that the man
is the father of his actions as of
children that is a person's character
shapes how she acts aristotle responds
by contending that her present character
is partly a result of previous choices
she made while this claim is plausible
enough it seems to pass the back since
the man is the father of those earlier
choices and actions too in the course of
history many philosophers tried to
refute the idea of free will and embrace
a more deterministic view of reality
determinism in the west is often
associated with newtonian mechanics and
physics which depicts the physical
matter of the universe as operating
according to a set of fixed noble laws
well you ask one of the deepest
philosophical questions of physics the
question of free will first of all
there's something called newtonian
determinism
newtonian determinism says that the
universe is a clock a gigantic clock
that's wound up at the beginning of time
and it's been ticking ever since
according to newton's laws of motion so
what you're going to eat 10 years from
now on january 1st has already been
fixed it's already known using newton's
laws of motion einstein believed in that
einstein was a determinist and some
people asked einstein well does that
mean that a murderer this horrible mass
murderer isn't really guilty of his
works because it was already preordained
billions of years ago
and einstein said well yeah in some
sense that's true
that even mass murderers were
predetermined but he said they should
still be placed in jail okay
heisenberg then comes along and proposes
the heisenberg uncertainty principle and
says nonsense
there's uncertainty you don't know where
the electron is it could be here here or
many places
simultaneously and this of course
einstein hated because he said god
doesn't play dice with the universe
well
hey get used to it einstein was wrong
god does play dice every time we look at
an electron it moves there's uncertainty
with regards to the position of the
electron so what does that mean for free
will
it means in some sense we do have some
kind of free will in the sense
that no one can determine your future
events given your past history there's
always the wild card there's always the
possibility of uncertainty in whatever
we do so this means that free will
determining the future hey these are
philosophical questions that seem to
indicate that we have some kind of free
will
sam harris writes in his book
losing a belief in free will has not
made me fatalistic in fact it has
increased my feelings of freedom my
hopes fears and neurosis seem less
personal and indelible there's no
telling how much i might change in the
future just as one wouldn't draw a
lasting conclusion about oneself on the
basis of a brief experience of
indigestion one didn't do so on the
basis of how one has thought or behaved
for vast stretches of time in the past a
creative change of inputs to the system
learning new skills forming new
relationships adopting new habits of
attention may radically transform one's
life the point harris tries to make is
also twofold first that our moral
interpretation of others actions should
be conducted under the prism of a
background check we stop hating others
because we think harder about the
origins of their actions and their
psychological and physiological
background we relate differently to
others when we understand them better
second that accepting that there is no
free will allows us to be more relaxed
in the face of absurdity and the
machinations of the cosmos this is
clearly a stoic view letting go of the
agency that free will dictates renders
one more capable of asserting control
over the things one can control
free will isn't free it comes at a cost
if you believe that there is no free
will the ghost is how to accept that the
idea of self doesn't matter anymore that
you just are that you are not the one
pulling the strings anymore you are not
in the cockpit of your experience you
are just floating in your experience but
maybe there is freedom in floating this
is a very liberating feeling for some
but it can also be a very disturbing
feeling for others rejecting free will
shouldn't make you a fatalist evolution
isn't an act of free will it is a part
of the mechanics of the cosmos that
tries to push us towards a certain state
i'm not really sure about the exact
future of that state i can only look at
human history try to recognize patterns
and offer a vague idea of the future
based on those patterns if on the other
hand you believe that there is free will
the cost is how to be a more responsible
human being the freedom to exercise your
will contains also your responsibility
to internalize morality and its
principles and strive for a universal
moral framework that will make
coexistence less arduous personally i
still haven't decided and both ideas as
implausible i understand what sam harris
wants to say that we are an amalgamation
of past experiences biological
mechanisms and environmental influences
and that we don't have control over all
that but we do have control over our
decision to understand all that to some
extent and how to orient ourselves in
the world according to our understanding
of all that we are all essentially part
of a big experiment called life it is
our moral duty to be more like the
scientist and less like the guinea pig
in that experiment
hey guys hope you enjoyed today's video
if you did make sure to like subscribe
turn on notifications and comment below
something cool please so that more
people can discover it
if you want to watch more videos from my
channel check out this one and this one
take care see you soon editor now
you